et
notre invité politique ce matin c'est
hervé marseille bonjour merci de nous
rejoindre la cei sénateur des
hauts-de-seine président du groupe union
centriste
ici au sénat on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes ou un interview en partenariat
avec la presse régionale représenté par
eric richard de la nouvelle république
bonjour eric bonjour en rien mon joueur
de marseille je finirai que d'être avec
nous on va évidemment parler de ce qui
se passe du côté du centre hervé
marseille mais d'abord l'actualité vous
l'avez sans doute vu hier ses dizaines
de milliers de manifestants qui ont
défilé dans plusieurs villes de france à
l'occasion du 1er mai et dans certaines
villes et notamment à paris la
manifestation est émaillée par des
violences est ce qu'aujourd'hui il est
devenu quasiment impossible qu'une
manifestation notamment à paris se
déroule sans violence et est ce que vous
redoutez un quinquennat marqué par la
violence et il ya déjà eu beaucoup de
violences dans le quinquennat passé on
se souvient des gilet jaune souvient des
manifestations sur l'hôpital
sur le pouvoir d'achat est
systématiquement effectivement il ya des
violences c'est insupportable on peut
plus protester si je veux dire des
filets marqués des opinions sans qu'il y
ait des gens qui viennent semer la
perturbation hier on a vu ces images
d'un pompier qui est agressée
franchement les pompiers sont là pour
servir la population et agressé des
pompiers c'est insupportable
condamne évidemment ces violences
inacceptables il a aussi pointé
l'absence de soutien jean luc mélenchon
aux forces de l'ordre il dit que c'est
un pompier pyromane compensons on sait
très bien que le pays est fracturée on
l'a vu dans les résultats du premier
tour de l'élection présidentielle on
sait que le quinquennat ne va pas être
facile qui va falloir faire des réformes
qui n'ont pas pu être fait à cause
notamment de la crise sanitaire et donc
on voit bien la difficulté de faire des
réformes dans ce contexte il y avait du
monde hier dans les rues et
gouvernement qui sera issu des urnes au
moins de juin aura fort à faire mais il
faut le faire si possible dans la
sérénité parce qu'on peut pas accepter
la violence et parmi les réformes qui
n'ont pas pu être fait la réforme des
retraites les manifestants demandaient
un retrait de cette réforme est ce que
pour vous et manuel mata on doit tenir
le cap sur cette réforme des retraites
avec un âge à 65 ans oui oui on l'a voté
d'ailleurs au sénat différentes reprise
on sait qu'ils créent les violences
malgré un climat social que je veux dire
un pays dans un état de droit il ya des
élus une majorité qui sort des urnes ni
un président qui est élu sur un
programme la réforme des retraites fait
partie de ce programme ça devait être
fait durant le quinquennat président
précédent ça n'a pas pu être fait il
faut absolument la faire on a un
problème pour vous il a été élu sur un
programme parce que l'opposition est
fière emmanuel me disait emmanuel macron
il a été élu contre marine le pen n'a
pas été élu pour faire ces réformes
qu'elle qualifiait n'ont pas d'incidence
à l'évidence il ya des gens qui ont voté
emmanuel macron pour éviter madame le
pen et c'est une bonne chose que madame
le pen n'ai pas été élu pour autant il a
quand même dit un certain nombre de
choses concernant ces réformes et la
réforme des retraites fait partie depuis
déjà plusieurs années des réformes qui
sont attendus et qui sont indispensables
et de maintenir 20 165 enfants écoutez
ça fera l'objet d'un débat au parlement
mais pour ce qui me concerne je je crois
que c'est indispensable sur ce
quinquennat qui qui commence justement
vous avez dit 3000 milliards de dettes
publiques ça suffit le quoi qu'il en
coûte ça suffit selon vous donc le
redressement des comptes de la nation
doit-il comme de doit-il débuter
maintenant et d'une manière plus
générale quels seront les réformes
prioritaires à vos yeux de ce
quinquennat elles ont été annoncées on
sait très bien qu'on peut pas continuer
à dépenser comme on l'a fait sur ce que
le président pour l'instant n'en a pas
fait une priorité immédiate c'est pas
immédiat mais enfin la cour des comptes
l'a rappelé régulièrement pas continuer
à dépenser comme on l'a fait ces trois
dernières années donc il va falloir
commencer à faire des économies on sait
qu'il ya cette réforme des retraites
celle de la dépendance on sait que il va
falloir mettre de l'argent
nos armes et compte tenu du contexte
international
on a un vrai problème de pouvoir d'achat
il va falloir évidemment le prendre en
considération ça fait partie des
fractures évidemment toutes les dépenses
la dépendance les armes et se voir
d'achat on les fait où les économies non
mais ça se discute c'est les petits
salaires en particulier donc c est ce
sont des vases qui se remplissent d'eau
qui solide et il va falloir avoir un
débat au moment du budget sur ces sujets
là on voit bien que le pouvoir d'achat
constitue un vrai problème dans la
société française et en particulier dans
ce qu'on appelle les territoires et puis
tout ce qui est institutionnel
on a vu que c'était également un
manquement
pour éviter oui tout à fait je vous en
vous en appelez donc un discours du dieu
gouvernement voulait vous l'avez dit
plus équilibré avec les collectivités
d'une part mais aussi avec le parlement
est ce que ça passe à vos yeux par une
réforme institutionnelle proprement dite
ou est-ce que c'est plus une question de
forme de style bahia les deux je veux
dire il ya la pratique institutionnelle
se travailler davantage avec le
parlement je crois tous les
parlementaires de quelque bord qu'ils
soient demande à travailler plus avec le
gouvernement déjà va falloir savoir
quelle majorité on le saura au mois de
juin à partir de là et on peut pas
rester dans cette situation
quelle que soit la majorité je pense en
particulier qui va falloir travailler
sur la proportionnelle on peut pas avoir
un pays morcelé comme celui-là avoir 56
% d'électeurs qui votent pour des partis
protestataires au premier tour et qui
seront faiblement
on peut le redouter représentés au
parlement ce qui crée forcément un
problème dans la rue
à la proportionnelle donc ça aussi de la
pédagogie je crois que ça il ya du
chemin il dit aujourd'hui il faut en
passer par là avec moi proportionnelle
est devenu indispensable alors la
proportionnelle ça veut tout dire et
rien dire toutes sortes de plessé ce que
j'allais me demander c'est proportionnel
pour forcer l intégrale comme l'a dit
macron comme l'envisagé manuel mann ans
durant sa campagne il faut garder une
certaine stabilité faut voir si c'est
départemental comme on l'a fait en 1986
enfin on doit pouvoir trouver une forme
de proportionnelle qui permet la
représentation des courants principaux
du pays et puis en même temps la
stabilité parce qu'on peut pas non plus
avoir un parlement qui soit totalement
instable alors on attend maintenant que
le président nomme un premier ministre
il se fait d'ailleurs beaucoup attendre
pensez vous qu'il puisse choisir un
centriste encore eût-il fallu qu'on
s'entende sur le terme de centristes et
si oui quel est celui ou celle qui
aurait éventuellement votre préférence
bah écoutez le problème c'est pas
d'avoir des préférences un la
constitution elle est très clair
contrairement à ce que dit monsieur
mélenchon on n'élit pas le premier
ministre il est désigné par le président
de la république c'est quelqu'un qui
correspond à la pierre angulaire de la
majorité et qui est en capacité de
travailler comme
n'importe quel j'allais dire que le
laboratoire avec le le principal
intéressé donc le problème ce n'est pas
d'avoir des préférences se nomme il a
distillé législatif puisque il me semble
acté que jean castex jusqu'aux
législatives
est-ce que là pour vous il faudra un
premier
niveau 10 mois de saumos capacités on
peut toujours avoir des idées
aucun souci sur le sujet c'est le
président qui décidera est-ce que vous
souhaitez que des centristes entre au
gouvernement
des centristes y en avait déjà au
gouvernement parce qu'il ya des variétés
j'ai des centristes
et donc qu'elle avait déjà au
gouvernement j'imagine que khaled encore
au gouvernement il ya du modem est ce
qu'il faut qu'il me dise pourquoi pas il
y aura peut-être des idées jusqu'à
présent j'en avais pas
si vous croisez vous n'êtes pas posée
est-ce que des idées rentrer au
gouvernement écoutez quand j'entends
nicolas sarkozy dire ce qu'il dit est
d'autres responsables de l air si je le
dise je vois pas comment les centristes
seraient seraient opposés à une idée
comme ça mais ça ne vous a pas échappé
qu'il y ait des différences entre la
direction dlr est ce que dit nicolas
sarkozy vous quelle est votre ligne est
ce que vous êtes pour la ligne
d'indépendance qui a été acté par
christian jacob et par la direction dlr
c'est à dire on n'est pas soluble dans
le maquereau nous est ce que vous dites
comme nicolas sarkozy et que oui il faut
travailler
je pense qu'il faut travailler avec la
majorité aujourd'hui on voit bien qui a
trois blocs
et pierre laurent qui m'a précédé à ce
micro vous l'a bien dit le bloc qui est
tiré par monsieur mélenchon s'organisent
pour des candidatures uniques donc
madame le pen à droite va l organiser
ces législatives et donc il ya un bloc
central qui reste
bien forcément des gens qui vont
travailler avec le gouvernement avec la
nouvelle majorité mais vous vous dites
emmanuel macron les républicains et les
centres et c'est le même bloc c'est un
bloc central mais du point de vue des
électeurs après que les responsables des
partis et des points de vue différents
mais je suis bien obligé de constater
que les électeurs ont choisi les
électeurs ont choisi et à partir de là
si quand on est démocrate faut respecter
les urnes j'ai du mal à voir comment on
se différencie du bloc central qui sera
premier ministre si jamais
les députés républicains étaient
majoritaires qui serait premier ministre
personnalité
il a refusé d'être candidat aux
présidentielles il accepterait d'être
candidat à matignon pourquoi pas oui
c'est possible tout est possible vous
savez on en voit tellement depuis
quelques mois et quelques années elle
j'ai pas eu l'occasion de le rencontrer
de l'interroger mais pour l'instant je
ne le vois pas
menant la campagne des législatives mais
juste pour conserver ou roux se situe
lui dit au début du quinquennat on se
souvient vous étiez plutôt proche des
manuels mâcon qu'après vous avez fait la
campagne présidentielle avec les élèves
vous avez soutenu la candidature de
l'aller le pks aujourd'hui vous êtes
tous nos électeurs nos électeurs sont
pour beaucoup chez emmanuel macron donc
l'idée y doit revenir en côte et
emmanuel macron pour vous grande partie
de gens à lui dit on des proximités avec
la majorité dans vous commandant vous je
suis pas hostile oui parce que on m'a
rien demandé donc je ne demande rien
mais je réponds à vos questions je pense
que il ya un bloc central est que ce
bloc central il faut en tenir compte
mais sauf qu'au sénat vous êtes dans la
majorité sénatoriale c'est à dire avec
les élèves c'est à dire dans
l'opposition est ce que vous resterez
dans l'opposition où est ce que vous
dites non même au sénat il faut qu'on se
rapproche des manuels macron nous au
sénat on est libre on est indépendant et
on veut être utile donc à partir de là
on verra bien d'abord qui va gagner les
élections législatives et quel texte
nous seront proposés on vote sur des
textes au sénat et vous restez dans la
majorité sénatoriale vous restez un
allié des républicains le problème c'est
pas d'être alliés des républicains
problème c'est qu'il faut qu'ils aient
des majorités
à un moment donné il faut qu'il y ait
des raids et des majorités si vous
faites une majorité avec le ps et le pc
ou fait une majorité des républicains
mais il y en a beaucoup d'autres est ce
que je sais ce que les candidats de
hesse qui aura des candidats d'abord
estampillé idéaux législatives où est ce
que ce sera des candidats communs avec
qui avec les l air ou avec la majorité
présents aujourd'hui il ya des il ya des
situations très particulières suivant
les départements il n'y a pas d'accord
général il ya des situations
particulières suivant les départements
donc ça sera au cas par cas y aura une
ligne directrice de l'unil c'est le cas
aujourd'hui et ça sera toujours le cas
pas dans mon département il ya aucun
accord n'aurait hauts-de-seine et il est
là que je je dirais qu'elle est un petit
peu l'état d'esprit au sein du groupe au
sénat on se souvient déjà que leurs vues
du quinquennat précédent la moitié de
votre groupe avait voté la confiance au
vert ministre qu'est ce qu'il en est
justement maintenant aujourd'hui je
pense je pense que la proximité avec la
majorité s'est renforcée s'est renforcé
et donc il ya une plus grande part est
un oui monsieur entend bien sûr et
beaucoup de sénateurs enfin une
vingtaine qui ont appelé à voter pour
emmanuel macron c'est en fait
au premier tour de cette élection et il
ya une volonté de liberté à une volonté
d'être utile de travailler sur des
textes et ne pas participer à des
opérations de de vote systématique entre
gaullistes et donc ces sénateurs
évidemment d'après ce qu'on en dit matin
ils ont toujours leur place dans votre
groupe aux côtés de sénateurs qui eux
sont plutôt pour l'indépendance du
groupe union centriste est pourri pour
un rapprochement avec les manuels macro
ç'a toujours été le cas c'est pop union
centriste comme son nom l'indiqué il ya
toutes sortes de deux sénateurs gasquet
unanimité dans votre groupe pour se
rapprocher des manuels macro louis dont
je veux dire encore une fois il ya des
points de vue divergents mais il ya une
volonté de travailler avec la majorité
qui s'est clairement exprimée bon voila
vous en avait parlé avec bruno
retailleau avec gérard larcher ça m'est
arrivé d'en parler avec qui vous disent
on imagine que vous n'êtes pas
complètement d'accord lattier t on verra
le moment venu quand il y aura des
élections que d'accord il y aura des
textes et qu'on sera appelé à voter
dessus déjà c'est pas uniquement une
question de vote de texte que gérard
larcher lui même dit qu'il est dans une
position constructive et qui ne vit pas
et qui ne dit pas non par deux ailes sur
cette même ligne écoutez il va y avoir
un premier ministre qui va être nommé le
problème initial faire une déclaration
de politique générale est ce que il
faudra la soutenir ou pas bon déjà c'est
le premier au point la dernière fois
effectivement il ya plus de 50% de mon
groupe qui avait qui avait soutenu
la confiance au premier ministre vous
savez cette des sénateurs neuf groupes
qui ont été appelés pour rentrer au
gouvernement pense notamment françoise
gatel qui a été une des premières à dire
dans votre groupe qu'il fallait voter
pour emmanuel macron qui est une grande
spécialiste des collectivités
j'ai pas été informé de sa en général
des lions les rarement
venir sur ce qui s'est passé à la
présidentielle 4,8 pour cent le score de
valérie pécresse quelle est pour vous la
raison de cette défaite historique pour
la droite et le centre
problème d'identification et de
programmes encore une fois quelle est la
différence avec
le le programme de monsieur mâcon
comment s'identifie
est ce qu'il ya une place et est ce
qu'il ya un espace aujourd'hui dans ce
bloc central pour se différencier
on voit bien que
madame le pen au demeurant un peu moins
mais monsieur zemmour est clairement
identifiée on voit bien que monsieur
mélenchon était clairement identifié sur
un certain nombre de thématiques bon
monsieur macron certes un contexte il a
bénéficié j'allais dire d'être le
sortant dans un contexte très difficile
avec la crise ukrainienne avec la crise
sanitaire bon mais comment on se
différencient je crois que cet espace là
n'existe pas aujourd'hui en
tous les cas s'il existe
il faut voir comment il existe parce que
jusqu'à présent on a vu que dans les
résultats il n'existait pas ou il
existait peu ça signale que pour vous un
parti comme les républicains est un
parti du dieu pas c'est quoi c'est un
espace qui reste à reconstruire en thème
de deux projets
comme le ps d'ailleurs
et avec quelle personnalité quand on
voit le nombre de personnalités j'ai les
républicains qui émettent
des préférences pour la majorité
monsieur macron c'est interroge quand
même et ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui pour
voulait l air et lui dit non plus de
place sur l'échiquier politique
en tout les
cette forme là parce que cette formule a
d'ailleurs monsieur mâcon va réinventer
sa majorité pour faire vivre toutes les
différences on voit bien que monsieur
mélenchon vous venez d'en parler et
pierre-laurent essaie d'organiser lui
aussi une gauche madame le pen essaie de
s'organiser c'est peut-être plus simple
chez elle mais ça suppose de tenir
compte des réalités électorales et
de s'il doit y avoir des espaces demain
de les recréer l élu d doivent aller
dans le parti unique ne soit emmanuel
macron donc ici si vous me demandiez si
les x et année un espace il faut que
pour exister cet espace doit se rénover
se reconstruire à partir
d'aujourd'hui il faut que
sarkozy par exemple nicolas sarkozy il
dit rien d'autre il dit dans la majorité
je les fais avec jacques chirac giscard
la faye pompidou c'est à l'intérieur
d'un grand ensemble qu'il faut se
reconstruire oui mais vous il faut pas
recréer quelque chose comme l'ump un
grand parti de la droite et du centre
vous dites aujourd'hui on doit aller
dans les dunes doit aller avec emmanuel
macron tout ça va dépendre de la façon
dont il construit la majorité le fait
d'avoir un parti unitaire est pas de
nature à
permettre des élus et de le rejoindre
bon suivant l'organisation
bon alors bien donc on n'en sait rien
aujourd'hui on n'en sait rien est-ce que
parmi les erreurs si on peut qualifier
ça d'erreur vous allez me le dire faites
par valérie pécresse c'est celle d'avoir
regardé trop à droite trop vers eric
ciotti au début de sa campagne oui je
crois je crois que
là la ligne la plus dure a été celle qui
a pris les choses en main et qu'à partir
de là je pense qu'il ya un espace au
centre qui a été désertée et qui a été
occupée par emmanuel maintenant donc
effectivement c'est un choix qui a été
fait on a vu que le résultat était pas
trop bon et elle aurait pas aujourd'hui
être un parti qui va de des centristes
dont xavier bertrand jusqu'à avec
chelsea c'est possible mais ça dépend
qui l'incarné comment avec quels projets
sur quelle base voilà c'est tout une
reconstruction on voit bien que monsieur
jacob renonce à se représenter que y
arrêter
il va mettre un terme à ses
responsabilités en septembre n'ont plus
rien à voir là aussi du renouvellement
qui qui sera à la tête des républicains
est ce que c'est quelqu'un qui est
plutôt
un tenant de la ligne qu'on va qualifier
de plus à droite où est-ce que c'est à
modéré et selon la personne selon si
c'est quelqu'un doit modérer ça dépendra
de ce que fait lille
ça a forcément des conséquences
si c'est quelqu'un de ma ligne à droite
comme bruno retailleau par exemple aura
une rupture entre l'idée et les
républicains n'ont mais on voit bien que
la capacité de rassemblement de
quelqu'un qui est sur des thématiques
beau nom n'est pas obsédé par le foulard
l'immigration ou la sécurité
ça fait partie des choses qu'il faut
traiter mais c'est pas non plus un
problème quotidien donc il ya les
problèmes on l'a dit de pouvoir d'achat
de réforme de l'europe les problèmes
sociaux territoriaux et nous on y est
très attaché pour ces législatives
le principal adversaire
qui à gauche avec mélenchon à partir du
moment où vous avez des blocs il faut se
souvenir que le mode de scrutin fait
qu'il faudra douze ennemis % des
inscrits pour être présent au deuxième
tour donc suivant la participation vous
allez peut-être est obligé de faire 17
18 voire 20 ou davantage % des exprimés
pour être présent si vous avez un
candidat d'union de la gauche si vous
avez un candidats lepénistes assez fort
on a vu qu'il y avait à peu près au
premier tour de 150 circonscriptions où
monsieur macron arriver en tête et y en
avait 200 6 où c'était madame le pen et
104 où c'était monsieur mélenchon ça
veut dire qu'il ya plus de trois cent
dix circonscriptions où c'est madame le
pen ou monsieur mélenchon si vous avez
des candidatures uniques et que vous
avez des candidatures ensuite de
dispersion bas pour être présent au
deuxième tour ça soit dans les eaux de
francs que ce soit en moselle
dans le grand test dans le sud de la
france il va falloir faire attention
parce que vous avez beaucoup de gens qui
seront pas présents deuxième tour vous
avez
plusieurs reprises indiqué que
finalement vous étiez plutôt favorable
un septennat qu'un quinquennat est-ce
que ça fluidifierait davantage la vie
démocratique est ce que ça permettrait
peut-être justement de donner davantage
sa chance à chaque formation de pouvoir
mieux s'exprimer en quelque sorte oui
mais je crois que les problèmes
institutionnels on peut pas les prendre
par tiroirs si je puis dire
oui je suis
davantage favorable au septennat mais je
suis hostile au fait surtout que les
députés soient élus le lendemain de
l'élection présidentielle parce qu'on
voit bien que ça donne c'est là que ça
fait un peu chambre d'enregistrement en
quelque sorte c'est voilà et puis il
faut revoir les conditions de travail
dans au parlement pouvait pas avoir un
pays qui est dirigé parce que c'est
comme ça aujourd'hui de façon
extrêmement rapide avec les réseaux
sociaux par des communiqués par des
tweets par des réponses immédiates à
travers le monde et puis m un an ou un
an et demi a voté un texte au parlement
il ya une inadéquation entre la
nécessité de répondre rapidement à
l'actualité de prendre des décisions
rapides parce qu'une crise iter parce
que il ya des conflits aux portes de
l'europe parce que ils se passent toutes
sortes de choses et on voit bien que le
l'exécutif répond immédiatement et puis
le parlement nuit mais un an parce qu'il
faut auditionner faut faire des
commissions faut vous était donc il faut
revoir les conditions de travail pour
j'allais dire permettre au parlement de
travailler plus rapidement et de
répondre aux attentes des français
merci à notre invité ce matin eric on
regarde la une de la nouvelle république
dans son édition d'andré loire week-end
meurtrier en indre et loire c'est à la
une de votre journal avec
merci eric d'avoir été avec no mercy
hervé marseille
[Musique]